thanks to skillshare for supporting this
episode of journey to the microcosmos
the first 1000 people to click the link
in the description can get a free trial
of skillshare's
premium membership
[Music]
recently we did an episode about sperm
and in it we talked about
the awkward history of how at times
humans have
overestimated the role of sperm it is
true
that sperm is essential to human
reproduction but the spermist school of
thought maintained that the sperm was
where
all of the important information
encoding our treats was located
and the egg while the egg was just there
to provide some nourishment
that point of view was wrong about how
genetic information gets passed along
but also it really just underestimated
the engineering
marvel that is the egg now it's easy to
focus on eggs and sexual reproduction
because for humans and many other
animals
the fertilization of the egg biosperm is
the key
step that drives the development of a
new embryo
and the meeting of sperm and egg is an
incredibly
valuable one allowing organisms to mix
and match
genes between individuals so that the
population can better evolve
and adapt
but not all sperm egg pairings introduce
variation
for example some flatworms are
hermaphroditic and under certain
conditions
they might fertilize their own eggs
in one species that process involves
injecting sperm
directly into their own head
but also while all sperm needs an egg
not all eggs
need sperm there are quite a few
organisms
like many gastrotricks and rotifers that
reproduce
by parthenogenesis
[Music]
in these species the female makes an
unfertilized egg that develops
and eventually hatches into a miniature
version
of its singular parent both
self-fertilization
and parthenogenesis come along with the
advantage that you do not have to find a
mate
you can just go ahead and get your own
egg going and that's
great if you want to grow a large
population or there just
aren't very many viable mating options
around but it does
come at the cost of genetic diversity
as an egg develops and the cells within
it divide and differentiate
there is a flurry of activity to support
them developing an organism
is an involved process it's not like you
have all your materials laid out in
front of you and all that's left is to
assemble those
pieces it's more like starting out with
one brick
and being told to make more bricks from
it and as you make more bricks from
those bricks you have to also make them
more and more specialized until you get
like a castle
now coming up with a comparison
inevitably sells the complexity of the
whole process
short in rota for eggs scientists have
found an uptick in genes
involved with cell proliferation
adhesion and communication
all of which make sense because there is
so
much coordination needed to make sure
that as cells divide they're talking to
each other
and assembling themselves correctly into
one of the most complex structures the
universe has ever seen
a living multicellular organism
now in addition to everything going on
inside the egg
there's everything going on in the world
around it
an egg that has been released into the
microcosmosis
subject to the environmental whims of
its surroundings
which makes it all the more remarkable
how many animals produce eggs that are
crafted to wait and survive those
conditions
for long periods of time
tardigrades for example can produce eggs
capable of withstanding extreme heat
and extreme cold as well as doses of
radiation that would kill
a human being those eggs however are
different from the ones that are
currently on your screen which are
hydrated and thus not able to survive
those extremes
they are only good at surviving these
wild circumstances when they've been
desiccated or dried out
those hearty eggs are called dormant or
resting eggs
which makes them sound inert and that's
kind of the point
the eggs are inactive their metabolism
essentially shuts down as does synthesis
of any new
dna rna or proteins what the eggs take
with them going into that state
is all that they have to survive like an
internal desert island
but it takes a lot of work to make that
inactivity
possible there are a lot of animals that
produce dormant eggs
and the conditions that drive that
dormancy and the way they emerge from it
vary according to that animal's
lifestyle and environment
for many rotifer species resting eggs
are the result
of sexual reproduction and an important
thing for us to note as you look at
these rotifer eggs
there are morphological features
specific to rotifer resting eggs
but we are not familiar enough with
those traits
to be able to make the call on whether
or not the eggs were looking at right
now
are resting or not resting now if we had
some decades
we might be able to tell you because
that's how long
some resting eggs can survive some
have even hatched after over 100 years
of rest but alas we definitely
do not have that long to wait
even if we're having a hard time telling
resting and non-resting eggs apart from
the outside
they are very different on the inside
these protections can be straightforward
like an abundance of proteins that
protect the egg from
heat and oxidative stress but on top of
protecting cells from external factors
the resting egg has to be protected from
itself
in animals apoptosis or programmed cell
death
is a necessary part of our survival it
helps our bodies clear out cells that
are no longer healthy or necessary
without it you and i would have already
died of cancer
but a cell in the desiccated dormant
environment of the resting egg
is not gonna look very healthy so
some animals like artemia have devised
molecular strategies that
interfere with the pathways that lead to
apoptosis
so that the cell can be left alive and
alongside those protections are stores
of messenger rna
also kept at rest and stabilized while
the egg is in stasis
those stores of rna contain the
instructions the egg needs
to move quickly when it emerges from its
resting state because
after decades or even a century of
waiting
once it's time to get going it's time
to get going and those instructions will
allow the egg to jumpstart the synthesis
of the proteins that it will need
to grow and divide and bring new life
back to the microcosmos wherever they
have ended up
[Music]
thanks for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us we would like to say
thank you again
to skillshare for supporting this video
did looking at those eggs make you
hungry
well probably not but once you've
regained your
appetite and feel like eating some eggs
again why not learn
how to use them in all new ways you can
learn many many things on skillshare
including how to cook
and with courses like make fresh pasta
the real
italian way you can learn to make fresh
pasta
using an egg dough chef nicoletta grippa
will
walk you through the ins and outs of
preparing pasta to perfection
and in the end you'll walk away feeling
inspired to cook pasta at home for your
family
and friends who will deeply appreciate
it
skillshare is an online learning
community that offers membership with
meaning
with so much to explore real world
projects to create
and support from fellow creatives
skillshare empowers you to accomplish
real growth it's curated specifically
for learning meaning there are no ads to
distract you
and they're always launching new premium
classes so you can stay focused
and follow wherever your creativity
takes you
and an annual subscription to skillshare
is less than ten dollars a month
if you're one of the first thousand
people to click the link in the
description you can get a free trial of
skillshare's premium membership
the folks on the screen right now they
are our patrons on patreon they allow us
to go on these journeys into the micro
cosmos and
learn more and then communicate that
learning with you
and we're so happy to have their support
and if you would like to become one of
them
you can do that at patreon.com
journey2micro
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss you can check
out jam and germs on
instagram or you can check out his new
book the hidden beauty of the
microscopic world
link in the description and if you want
to see more from
us there is always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
you